seit donald trump im weißen haus wohnt
sind wir ja alle kummer gewohnt aber in
dieser woche muss man so sagen haben die
deutsch amerikanischen beziehungen
wirklich einen neuen tiefpunkt erreicht
es ist wirklich so
das us-handelsministerium sieht deutsche
autos offiziell als bedrohung für die
nationale sicherheit der usa
was für ein schlag gegen unsere mit
abstand ehrlichste branche meine damen
und herren
schon in den nächsten wochen könnte
donald trump vettel strafe verhängen
kurz gesagt wenn man unser aktuelles
verhältnis zu den amerikanern mal
symbolisch darstellt mit hilfe der
beiden button tiere dann sind wir
eindeutig der passen gebracht er hat uns
vorher nicht mal zum essen eingeladen ja
so diese neuigkeit im transatlantischen
verhältnis hat man auch sehr schön bei
der münchner sicherheitskonferenz
gesehen und zwar als donald vize mike
pence an einer bestimmten stelle seiner
rede
reichlich applaus eingeplant hatte jaha
wie schöne grüße von donald trump was
sagt man dazu ja
ich glaube beim bundeskongress der
manisch-depressiven ist bessere stimmung
wirklich
und wenn sie das gerade schon unangenehm
fanden dann gucken sie sich mal den
director's cut an
[Musik]
ja
[Applaus]
wirklich minimal von uns bearbeitet
wahrscheinlich hat mister penz gedacht
ja gut das ist halt ein deutsches
publikum er die die gehen nicht so aus
sich raus diese verklemmten kraut aber
dann gab es in münchen eben auch diese
bilder standing ovations und zwar jetzt
kommt nach einer rede von angela merkel
so viel applaus hat sie zuletzt gekriegt
als sie den cdu vorsitz abgegeben
ja ja sie haben ganz richtig gehört
merkel hat da eine super rede gehalten
mit wie hast nur diese eine sache die
sie gar nicht kann emotionen genau
richtige emotionen sie hat trump und die
us-politik frontal angegriffen das muss
man wirklich so sagen das war wahnsinn
unsere kanzlerin die deutsche kanzlerin
ist jetzt offiziell die große
hoffnungsträgerin der multilateralismus
und begriffen multilateralismus
denn wenn mehrere länder
zusammenarbeiten um die welt besser zu
machen
nicht zu verwechseln mit
multilateralismus das ist wenn man eine
gas pipeline aus russland baut mit
seinem scheißegal ist wie die anderen
europäer dass finden
ja ja so läuft das nämlich hier im
ernstfall heißes germany first er hier
ist menschlich voll enttäuscht
deutschland baut diese pipeline nach
russland und bezahlt milliarden für
russisches gas
was soll das was soll das denn
doch gefälligst unser flüssiggas und
nicht bei gas putin hier ja ja wirklich
total vergiftete stimmung
auch beim thema rüstung sicher wir
deutschen haben 2014 wohl mal zugesagt
dass wir uns auf dieses blöde zwei
prozent ziel bei der rüstung zu bewegen
aber da waren wir besoffen ja kommen
können ja die anderen nato staaten
machen ist unsere ganz ehrlich ist uns
völlig egal was wir alles versprechen
klimaziele beschreiben irgendwas auf und
machen was anderes keine frage es wäre
schon schön wenn deutschland man so was
ähnliches wie eine außen- oder
sicherheitspolitische strategie hätte
statt immer nur auf konferenzen klug zu
scheißen aber das muss wollen uns noch
nicht sagen wie wie auf dem kasernenhof
manager
viele unserer nato verbündeten müssen
mehr tun die usa erwarten von reden und
mitglied einen glaubwürdigen planung
dass zwei prozent ziel zu erreichen den
plan haben wir fertig den faxen wir euch
am 30 februar kannst du dich darauf
verlassen
das kann doch alles nicht wahr sein es
kann nicht wahr sein womit die
amerikaner recht haben leider
natürlich müssen wir unsere deutschen ex
kämpfer zurücknehmen sind zwar
gefährliche psychose aber das sind
unsere psyche begeisterte fans der
scharia die im ernstfall lieber in einem
rechtsstaat wie deutschland vor gericht
stehen möchten müssen wir reinlassen
vox hat schon die passende serie
gut bei kali wort die rückkehr war der
deutsche scan von yussuf al almani
eigentlich kevin paschulke packt in
syrien seine koffer der gelernte
türsteher aus wuppertal möchte sein
glück in der alten heimat versuchen wird
kevin es schaffen als jungunternehmer
durchzustarten
erster rückschlag die jobbörse xing hat
keine einzige freie stelle für gefährder
scheiße doch das jobcenter vermittelt
den juni es aussteiger als bademeister
in einem spaßbad nächste station
aushilfe im nagelstudio
aber dann macht er denn doch noch seinen
großen traum wahr und wird zumba lehrer
in chemnitz das alles bei goodbye
kalifat die rückkehr kubas oder keppeln
bringt durchringen
dies ist
[Applaus]
so kommt es jetzt zwischen uns und den
usa tatsächlich zum ganz grossen
handelskrieg hoch spannende frage wie
nehmen die spannung mal direkt haus
schola alarm
serdar somuncu verrät uns schon jetzt
wie der handelskrieg deutschland usa
ausgeht
hallo amerika gewinnt ist so lala
dezember seine schuhe war nur spaß
ich kann es noch erklären also folgendes
wird passieren der irre trump haut 25
prozent auf deutsche autos und jetzt hat
die financial times eine liste gelegt
mit fünf produkten die wir europäer
deinen gegenzug mit strafzöllen belegen
achtung kein witz ketchup rosinen
pflaster koffer und tief gefrorener
fisch
damit sind die usa offiziell erledigt
wenn keiner mehr ihre berühmten rosinen
mit ketchup kauft alternativ hätte man
natürlich auch die seit jahren
versprochene digital steuer für google
facebook und amazon einführen können
also die idee dass konzerne die bei uns
geld verdienen was davon ja quasi
abgeben oder wie eine weise alte
schamanin aus der uckermark mal völlig
zu recht gesagt hat 'natürlich ist dass
ich in ordnung dass google amazon
facebook und wie sie alle heißen keine
steuern in europa zahlen das ist nicht
in ordnung und das machen wir genau so
weiter frankreich führt jetzt im
alleingang 3 prozent digital steuer ein
und wer hat dafür gesorgt dass sonst
keiner mit macht in europa war eine
rhetorische frage wir ein grund dafür
die interessen der deutschen
autoindustrie
sie wäre von einer reaktion der usa am
stärksten betroffen
vor diesem druck ist finanzminister olaf
scholz eingeknickt ganz genau denn das
wissen wir doch alle noch aus unserer
kindheit wenn dich ein schlägertyp wie
trump terrorisiert musst du ihm
unbedingt in allem nachgeben aber aber
kommen also das mit dem gefrorenen fisch
und den pflastern
das funktioniert bestimmt auch wie
gesagt die usa gewinnen weil deutschland
sich wie immer ein nest
deswegen setzen wir jetzt auch unsere
fahne durch eine
feinripp unterhose mit
[Musik]
dezember in münchen
da wird doch schon
[Applaus]
dollar
das ende des handels ja ich schließe
mich der prognose an diese zölle werden
kommen sie sind zwar auch für die
us-wirtschaft die dümmste aller optionen
aber genau das macht sie so attraktiv
ja der mann ist schon wieder im
wahlkampfmodus deswegen hat er ja gerade
auch den nationalen notstand ausgerufen
nur möchte ich so eine blöde mauer zu
mexiko zu kriegen
wo ist denn da der notstand jetzt mal
ernsthaft nationale notstand ist wenn
außerirdische washington angreifen oder
keine ahnung der netflix server abstürzt
allein die vorstellung des darms mit
meiner frau reden
naja aber das wichtigste wenn man so
einen notstand verkündet dann muss das
extrem dramatisch klingen auf keinen
fall darf man verraten das ist
eigentlich gar nicht eilt gut verstärkt
jürgen gebildet haben diese drei idioten
schwerste ja es ist so schön sich
vorzustellen wie in solchen momenten
seine berater danebenstehen und decken
wir haben doch alles aufgeschrieben in
riesigen buchstaben ja wirklich kein
mensch will diese mauer niemand niemand
will diese mauer
ja die illegale einwanderung aus mexiko
geht seit jahren kontinuierlich zurück
dass fakt sämtliche experten auch aus
der grenzregion übrigens haben schon
gesagt diese mauer ist eine
mittelalterliche erfindung die keines
unserer probleme löst sieht er ganz
anders
ja ja ja das rad ist älter als die mauer
das sind die großen menschheitsthemen
iks das bekam jetzt aber
[Applaus]
also erst die mauer
jetzt die schlechte nachricht diese
frechen kleinen mexikaner er finden ja
auch sachen als antwort auf james mauer
hier mexikos ex präsident mit einer
anderen knaller idee luca disc ist
gewahrt da wurde gerade angesagt genial
oder da musst du erstmal drauf kommen
nicht schlecht leider ist dieser
nationale notstand auch ein direkter
angriff auf gewaltenteilung und
demokratie in den usa wir schalten wir
live nach washington zu unserem
korrespondenten christian ehring
jährigen sind die usa unter trump auf
dem weg zur autokratie autokratie naja
ich weiß nicht natürlich schämt sich der
donald vor seinen kumpels kim jong-un
putin weil er immer dem löten kongress
fragen muss wenn noch mal geld braucht
muss immer betteln darf ich eine mauer
bitte bitte darf ich eine mauer
das ist peinlich dafür wirst du auch
nicht präsident notstand er hat jetzt
leider so einen mobilen notstands knopf
auf den er jedes mal drücken kann wenn
ich irgendwann nervt es ihm nicht geben
dürfen ja weil sie diesmal den notstand
ich höre gerade job ist unterm solarium
eingeschlafen
und sein toupet hat feuer gefangen das
neue coupé werden die mexikaner bezahlen
das ist ja klar ist ja klar aber er ist
nun stand ist leider überhaupt nicht
lustig in einer demokratie hat das
parlament den schlüssel zur kasse und
sonst keiner demokratie ist aber ne
total mittelalterliche erfindung sowie
das rad am ende entscheiden hier sowieso
gerichte über den notstand darüber hat
der präsident jetzt sogar ein lied
geschrieben und das ist mir aber ganz
egal da setzt sich in großen haufen
drauf
ich bin der präsident ich will jetzt
meine mauer
ja das lied ist super er in keine frage
keine frage aber zwang selber hat doch
immer gemeckert wenn obama damals am
kongress vorbei regiert hat statt
kompromisse mit denen zu finden hier
original ausschnitt von 2015
das war eine völlig andere situation
das kann man überhaupt nicht vergleichen
da war ein schwarzer präsident
das sind jetzt nur wieder breaking news
aus dem weißen haus
wir schauen noch mal in die usa us
präsident donald trump ist zu dick
diesmal hat melanie a den notstand
ausgerufen
660 staffel die bombardieren sämtliche
mcdonald's filiale
dank nicht bürgerkrieg christian
irgendwann da man sagt ja mein arzt hat
mir verboten mich weiterhin so
aufzuregen
deswegen wollte ich euch allen einfach
nur einen schönen tag wünscht überall
lassen ihre texte risiken liegen und ihr
lasst jetzt das xenix ein beschissenes
autobahn
[Musik]